um so there's been about 19 increase in  calls for service associated people with  mental distress  to include domestic violence there's  been a significant increase around 17  percent  domestic violence calls aside from the  domestic violence situations which  of course are always unfortunate are you  seeing these calls lead to other violent  incidents too yeah we you know we've had  a significant increase in  415 a's which stands uh with the assault  with the weapon  year to date in 2020 it's not dissimilar  to what's occurring across the united  states but here in particular it's a  concerning  stat for us and a lot of that is  directly related to the emotional aspect  of domestic violence so um there has  been a correlation with the increase in  domestic violence in 415 a's  and us us having to deal with those  investigations more often than not now  so it's a troubling trend  we are fully aware of it and we're doing  the best we can with our resources to  address it all right well